health is the most valuable thing we
have in life but we tend to forget that
until we lose it we're living longer
than ever before which is great but an
unforeseen consequence of this is that
we also spend a larger and larger
portion of our lives being sick getting
old currently means spending more time
in pain so scientists are trying to
shift the attention of the medical
community from optimizing lifespans to
optimizing health spans the part of our
lives during which we're disease free to
do this we need to attack the root cause
of almost all bodily defects aging
itself unbeknown to most people the
science of Aging has made enormous
progress in the last few years with
human trials about to begin in the near
future let's look at three examples of
discoveries that might benefit people
who are alive right now
[Music]
one senescent cells your cells have an
expiration date each time one of your
cells divides it copies its chromosomes
because of the way this works they lose
a tiny bit of DNA at the ends this could
be catastrophic so to protect themselves
we have long segments of DNA called
telomeres that sort of act like the
stiff bits at the end of shoelaces but
they shrink with every cell division in
some cells after a number of divisions
the telomeres are gone and the cell
becomes a zombie the senescence cell
senescence cells stay around and don't
die the older you get the more of the
MER are inside you they harmed tissue
around them and are linked to many
diseases that accompany old age like
diabetes and kidney failure but what if
you could kill them off scientists
genetically engineered mice so that they
could destroy their senescence cells as
they pleased older mice without
senescence cells were more active their
hearts and kidneys worked better and
they were less prone to cancer overall
they lived up to 30 percent longer and
in better health than average mice since
we can't genetically engineer all of the
cells in the human body we need to find
another way to get rid of our senescence
cells but how do we kill them without
harming healthy cells most cells in the
body commit a programmed cell suicide
when they're damaged but senescence
cells don't it turns out that they under
produce a protein that tells them when
it's time to die so in a late 2016 study
mice were given an injection of this
protein it killed 80 percent of all
their senescence cells while causing
almost no harm to healthy cells the
treated mice became Germany healthier
and even regrew lost hair as a result
there are a number of new companies
looking at treatments involving
senescence cells and the first human
trials will start soon
to NAD+ cells are made for hundreds of
millions of parts there the structures
machines messages and the catalysts that
make reactions happen all these parts
constantly need to be destroyed cleaned
up and rebuilt as we age this process
becomes less effective and so parts
become crumpled bunched up or are
removed slower or they are no longer
produced in the quantities we need one
of these parts is an ad plus a coenzyme
that tells ourselves to look after
themselves as age 50 we only have about
half as much in our bodies as we do at
age 20 low amounts of it are linked to a
whole bunch of diseases from skin cancer
to Alzheimer's cardiovascular disease
and multiple sclerosis but NAD+ can't
enter cells so we can't get it as a pill
but scientists notice that other more
flexible substances could enter cells
and would then turn into an AV plus
insight in 2016 multiple trials on mice
showed that they boosted the
multiplication of skin brain and muscle
stem cells they were rejuvenated had a
higher ability to repair their DNA and
had a slightly increased lifespan this
even got NASA interested which is
looking for a way to minimize the DNA
damage astronauts would be exposed to
from cosmic radiation on Mars missions
there are human trials being planned
right now but it's too soon to say if
this will boost our health span or even
lifespan but NAD+ is a serious candidate
and could become the first human
anti-aging pill three stem cells
stem cells are like cell blueprints that
sit at various places in the body and
copy themselves to produce a steady flow
of fresh young cells but they decline as
we age and so we decline to without new
parts human bodies break in mice
scientists observed that as the stem
cells in their brains disappeared they
started to develop diseases so they took
stem cells from baby mice brains and
injected them directly into the brains
of middle-aged mice
more specifically the hypothalamus a
part that involved in regulating a lot
of bodily functions the fresh stem cells
reinvigorated older brain cells by
secreting micro rnas that regulated
their metabolism after four months brain
and muscles worked better than those of
untreated mice and on average they lived
ten percent longer another study took
stem cells from mice embryos and
injected little directly into the hearts
of older mice as a consequence they had
improved heart function could exercise
20% longer and whiffy enough their hair
regrew faster
what all of this tells us is that there
is not a single magic bullet with which
to cure aging it requires a complex
array of different therapies we can kill
off senescence cells to clear away the
junk give ourselves fresh new stem cells
to fill the gap
all while regulating the metabolism of
the other cells using medication this
video comes with a big caveat after all
these studies have been carried out on
mice there's no guarantee the same
therapies would work in us to the same
extent but they are proof of concepts to
learn more about how we can modify our
own healthspan
we need human trials we've only covered
a tiny part of the research that's being
done right now and only scratched the
surface of these ideas the field of
healthspan extension needs more
attention and funding if it gets it all
of us might enjoy growing old without
lane if you now want to support the
research on Aging directly you can do so
at lifespan dot IO a community of people
actively supporting the scientists
working to cure aging check them out to
learn about the latest advances and
visit their blog or group on Facebook
the lifespan team also kindly supported
the creation of this video with a
donation and their expertise if you want
to help us make more of our videos you
can do so on patreon calm
[Music]